it's my great pleasure to introduce jodi
levy
jody is a researcher
at the institute for artificial
artificial intelligence research
institute which is part of the spanish
research council uh he has done
a lot of great work in the context of
sat
max ad solvers automated deduction
higher order logics and unification
algorithms
and in particular he has done uh he's
been a leader
in the space of trying to understand the
structure
of industrial instances and
connecting that structure with
potentially why sat solvers
might be efficient for uh large
industrial instances
so today is going to talk about formal
characterization of industrial sat
instances
so without further delay jody the online
forum is yours
thank you okay thank you very much vijay
for the introduction
uh what i will explain today is uh
what we have done in the last 10 or 12
years
in the form of characterization of the
industrial set instances
that is more or less the time that i've
been working in set
and basically i will talk about
my work with carlos and sotegi maria
lisa bonet and my student
jesus her audit so
sorry if i talk basically only about
our work and
i will try to be very
brief so i i will only explain the main
results that we
have got about the this characterisation
of the industrial
instances um
well you can you can interrupt me during
my talk but i
i will ask you to interrupt by the
microphone because
i cannot see the the chat
so if you make questions in the chat
i cannot see them okay thank you very
much
so if you want to answer the question of
what is an industry of certain instances
of that instance so probably the
we we have to answer the question of
what is a random step instance before
so uh when i started to work in in set
there was only one model of random set
instances that was
quite simple it was the the classical
law or the uniform model
where what you do is to repeat and many
times or the number of clauses that you
want to get
you sample k distinct variables
with uniform probability so we thought
repetitions of variables in this
so in this way you avoid the generation
of of
of simplified simplifiable
classes or tautologies and then you
negate each one of this
variable with probability one half
this model has been studied by the
theoretician
so we know a lot about the difficulty
for
uh solving this this random instances
we know that they are difficult for
resolution with high probability for
instance we have studied the
phase transition point and many other
properties
but to be honest uh
these properties are very little
interest or practitioners so
i mean for the people that implement
such solvers
because they don't help them to
to improve that such horrors
so if you make the question uh to uh
uh uh more practical people
of what is an industrial set instance
probably
the best answer you can get is that a
stat
an industrial set instance is what you
can get in the benchmarks of the
sub competition so the people who
implement
such holidays what try to do basically
is to win the competition
so they check the benchmarks that you
have in
the repository and you try to make
yourself so very efficient
uh solving this these instances
when we work in this with these
instances and we analyze them
so we take them as uh as the subject of
interest that we want to analyze
sometimes encompassing incomprehensible
they insist on taking the last uh the
the instances of the last competition so
but it doesn't matter very much because
you have to take the last
soldiers but not necessarily the last
instances because
all of them are industrial in principle
so uh one of the when you consider
these two kinds of instances i mean the
random instances and industrial
instances one of the first problems you
get is that
the solvers either do
well with the random instances or they
do well
with industrial instances so the solvers
that win in one of the
tracks of the competition do whatever
but in the other track and vice versa
there is of course another problem that
is that
uh probably there have been some kind of
co-evolution of these instances with the
solvers i mean
there's like a evolution of the set of
instances that we use
to test the solvers and the evolution of
the solvers
because uh when an instance is too easy
for all the solvers they are removed
from the benchmarks and when a set of
instances
of industrial instance it is too
difficult for all the solvers
they are also removed from the instances
for from the bench set of benchmarks so
probably
what we get in the set of benchmarks is
simply what we are able to solve with
the
modern sub solvers nowadays
so uh from the
point of view of somebody that works in
theories
and want to help the people working in
practice
uh there are many questions that can be
of interest for for the more practical
people
uh the first question is um
trying to characterize the difficulty of
set instance
oh well of course all the work in in in
in proof complexity tries to to answer
this this question but the problem is
that
we know that such solvers basically are
basically based on on
on under solution so if you have
uh proof systems stronger than
resolution
it's not too much of interest for for
for the people doing that that's that's
all worse
sorry if i i'm too provocative with my
my statements
so one of the questions that we tried to
to answer was to characterize
the difficulty of certain instances of
industrial settings and from a practical
point of view
we know that there is one of these
characterizations is the existence of
backdoors so there are
set of variables that once instantiated
make the formula very easy and this set
of
backdoor variables are
quite reduced in practice here i will
i will describe another characterization
that
is called harness or tree-like
refrigeration space
then there is another question that is
the study of the structural properties
of these industrial instances
here during my talk i will introduce the
scale-free structure the modularity
and the fractal dimension of such
instances
and finally the first question that i
will
try to to focus is the
proposal of new models of random
formulas
that try to capture these
properties of industrial instances
better than the
uniform random model so i will describe
basically three
models the scale three is that
random model the modular random model
and the popularity and similarity random
model
so this is basically the index of my
talk
and of course at the end uh there is a
fourth
question that it's always the same and
it's the question that uh
i we always get during my talks that
this
uh can be summarized show me the money
so uh
how all this work can help me to improve
the sub solver so if you motivate
if our motivation was to try to help
people developing such solvers in
practice
so uh we have to show the
some contributions and by the moment
these contributions are very very very
reduced
so uh let's start with the first part of
my talk that
we'll try to answer the first question
the characterization of
how difficult is settings and some
practice
we note that uh on most
industrial instances there are a
backdoor uh
set of variables that when instantiated
makes the formal articular
trivially decidable but the problem is
that
this set of backdoors is hard to find
but if you know that it is a reduced set
maybe it makes sense to try to find the
set before
trying to solve the formula so it makes
sense to use
heuristics to decide which variables
are more important to instantiate or to
make decision on them
so we know that in practice most
industrial instances
have a bacterial set that represents
less than one percent of variables even
one per thousand of the variables of
the problem so
uh from a theoretical point of view we
what we want to do is to find a measure
and an algorithm that given a formula
uh this measure describes the exponent
of a
polynomial algorithm from this on this
kind of formulas
of course uh the first nation that
uh comes to your head is the width
you know that there are ways that work
on on time and to the width of the
formula
but the product is that sorry can i ask
a question
yeah did you get this one-person number
by do you have a tool that computes the
backdoor size
or provides an upper bound of the back
door size
sure sorry so you say on
industrialization
you said that in industrial instances
there are backdoor sets of less than one
percent of the variables
right um i'm assuming that you have a
tool that computes the backdoor
size for individuals no no the
competition of the backdoor sizes
is hard so how do you know this
yeah so so you have to do it by brute
force
and get an approximate upper bound for
for the size of this set okay so i'm
assuming you have a tool to do that
no no no no no of course it's it's a
hard problem
so you can use heuristics to to find
promising variables and try to
instantiate them
and get an upper bound to the sets to
the size of this backdoor but
you cannot get the the exact size of the
backdoor
yeah but your your approximation uh
there must be a tool that computes this
approximation yeah
yeah you just you simply use the uh uh
uh such folder for this purpose
so decide the sad server in fact what
tries to find
the the backdoor in some way because he
tries to find the more promising
variables to instantiate this is what it
tries to say you can modify the search
orbit to try to reduce the
the computed uh band or set
but okay
so somehow you're able to say by running
this that's over then you're able to
estimate
the size uh i still don't quite
get how you do that but anyway let's
take it offline uh the other question is
uh one percent of a formula with a
million variables
is still quite large number of variables
so yeah of course yeah yeah so you can
just
make for instance using the such hover
you can estimate the number of decisions
you have done
and and the rest of variables are
propagated so this means that
you only have to decide around one
percent of the variables and the rest
are propagated by unit propagation
yeah that's fair but you have an
experiment to
establish this i'm assuming yeah yeah it
was done
many years ago in 2007 by carl agonis i
think
okay
so here i propose a little
a distinct uh measure
so with the back doors the problem is
that the set of variables that you try
to instantiate is
always the same in all the branches of
the
of the sub solver but probably you don't
need to
instantiate the same variables or to
decide the same
set of variables in all the branches of
the sat solver
so that the idea is uh
let let me introduce the stroller of a
tree that's a very uh
old nation for trees the solar farm note
of
a single note tree is a zero and the
stroller of
a tree is the if
the for a binary tree if both
if both subtrees have the same stroller
then you have to add one to the scholar
of
the complete tree otherwise you take the
maximum of the solid of both trees
this way the trees with australian wine
are exactly the caterpillars so they are
aligned
with only one branch in one of the sides
the streets with stroller 2 are
caterpillar with the la with
where the legs of the caterpillar are at
the same time
caterpillars and so on
um the notion of so
then you can compute the stroller or the
minimum australia
of unsatisfiable formula as the minimum
sprawler of a tree-like refrigeration of
the formula
this is also called uh the tree-like
refrigeration space
by vincent galesi and
and was also called harnessed by coleman
in 2003
so it's a notion that it's i think quite
natural and have been proposed by
different people and in parallel more or
less
so uh using this notion uh
the set of form clauses uh
can be proved with uh this kind of
refutation
so with a caterpillar refrigeration so
home classes corresponds to the
formulas that have stroller one
and at the same time uh what you can
prove with unit propagation only
with unique propagation is refutation of
formulas with a scholarly one so
stroller to astrology corresponds to a
little bit more difficult formulas than
done for clauses
uh the notion of a stroller of or
of space would be like a space
refutation or
hardness whatever you you name it
it has a nice properties for instance if
you have the empty class then the
stroller is zero
if you instantiate a formula the
stroller decreases
and for any formula
there exists an instantiation of one of
the variables
that strictly decrease the scalar of the
formula when this variable is
distantiated by
one of the true values
and the stroller is the minimum
measure that satisfy all these three
properties
we have an old algorithm
that works on time and through the
stroller of the former is the impetus
algorithm and uh we can also prove
that the stroller of a formula is
smaller than the back door
that the size of the back door of
variables
so it's more
quite natural and in some ways
more appropriate and measured than the
the director size
any question
so uh on practice we have analyzed the
stroller of some industrial instances it
was a
work done more than 10 years ago so we
only used uh
we used a such solver that was not using
learning
so there is not an extension or
a natural extension of the
the notion of australia for for
refutation
for resolute for general resolution and
for
such large using learning so in this
in this in this analysis of industrial
instances we use this
research hallway without learning and we
uh computed the stroller of the
refutation of the trilog refutation
found by the search solver and we
thought that the
stroller of the of most industrial
instances
is smaller than the one percent of the
form of the variables of the formula
i have a question so you mentioned that
uh
horn formulas always have stroller one
right
yes because you need one unit
propagation and
so do you have a characterization of
which formulas would have constant power
constant with constant space
no good question
so any other family that would have
constant tower you don't know
no okay thank you
but probably i don't know but
maybe there is an answer
so let's let's start with the second
part of my
talk that is the description of some
properties that we have analyzed and in
the cell instances
so uh we are talking about structural
properties so the first thing we do is
with the industry with the industrial
instance is to
transform the industrial instances into
graphs
and we will use properties that have
been studied for
graph of our networks so there are two
ways to
transform a formula into a graph
one is to consider a node for variables
and
four clauses and and use the incidence
graph
that describes when a variable occurs
positive or negatively
in a class and the other is a
graph where you only have nodes for
variables and you connect two variables
when there is a clause that contains
both
so in some cases i will use one kind of
graph and in the other
the the bypass this bipartite graph and
in the other cases
we will use the the the graph that only
contains
nodes for variables
so the first property we studied was the
scale for the structure of the set
instances
what we do what we did at the time was
to analyze
the instances used in the set 2008
competition so if you take
all the instances in the competition and
you so you put
them all together and you sort the
variables
of all the formulas in the competition
according to the number of occurrences
you get a representation like this one
so you discover that
in that competition most of the
variables only of course five times
in the formula but the average number of
occurrences is 13
because there are a few variables at the
core
even millions of times in the formula
if you represent the number of
occurrences
uh using double logarithmic axis
you discover that it approximates very
close to a line
so this means that the expected number
of occurrences of the
y most frequent variable follows a power
law distribution with an exponent close
to
0.82
and at the same time if you choose
randomly
uh one of these variables the
probability that this variable occurs
k many many times also follows an
overall distribution with an exponent
close to
2.22
you can repeat the analysis here we have
the analysis for the
rdt of the variables so you discovered
that the rit of the variables of the
number of occurrences of the variable in
the bipartite
graph follows up overload distribution
with an exponent
well here it's with a different
technique we
estimate the exponent into 2.29 in
instead of 2.22
and also for the rarity of the closed
notes that
represents the size of the clauses
you also find that the sizes of the
clauses also
follow a power law distribution
but with a
[Music]
little bigger exponent close to
3 or 3.03
the tail of the distribution of the
sizes of
the classes decays faster than in the
case of variables
probably because in the qualifications
you try to avoid
huge or big very big classes
so the next natural question is
what happens when you try to solve the
formula so during the execution of the
flat solver
is this scale-free structure modified
so it seems natural that if you have
variables that are called
thousands or millions of times in the
formula so
the best thing you can do is to
instantiate this
those variables because they make the
formula decreasing very much
so what we did was uh
using one of the of the industries at
solvers
in a mini set we let miniside work for
1000 seconds and we analyzed
the formula after after
uh in the longest of the
of in the longest branch that has uh
analyzed the mini set during this uh
1000 seconds
in this long branch there are
a lot of variables instantiated
however if we compare the distribution
of derivatives of the original formula
with the distribution of the artists
of the formula where a lot of variables
have been instantiated
we observe that the distribution is
almost the same so the solver
does not try to destruct to destroy
the scale free structure of the form or
with instantiations
we know that the sub solver also
introduce
new clauses during the search so there
is the learning
so we can also consider the original
formula
adding the learn clauses here in blue
or the original formula plus the learned
clauses
instantiated and we observe that in
all the cases the power law distribution
is preserved
even with the addition of the learned
clauses it seems that the
power of distribution is reinforced
in some way because the exponent of the
power law distribution is
decreasing
so we can conclude that the
in some way the such solver tries to
exploit
this scale for this structure and does
not try to destroy it
so even it seems natural to try to
instantiate the variables that occur
more often in the formula
is not what the subtropic stretch to do
during the search and
the addition of learn classes seems to
contribute
to reinforce this skill free structure
so we can do just another experiment
we can start with a perfectly random
formula a uniform
generated with a uniform distribution so
here is the formula in red
so since the formula is a random formula
generated with a random distribute with
a uniform distribution
the rdt of the variables decays
exponentially
very fast so there are
sorry uh you'll have to speed up a
little bit we don't
you've already at the 30-minute mark
oh sorry yeah please speed up a little
bit thank you
yeah so um what we observed is that
uh using a a uniform random formula
the addition of learn clauses makes the
formula scale free
so even if the formula is not a skill
free like in the random formulas
the learning tries to
to to to make it uh scale free
we have also analyzed the modularity of
industrial formulas the modularity is
an ocean used for graphs it tries to
find uh the composition of the graph
into subsets such that the number of
inner edges connecting
nodes in the same partition its height
and the number of edges connecting
distinct partitions
is low uh
the modularity can be defined as the
number of
inner edges divided by the total number
of h's minus the expected number of
linear edges for a random graph with the
same degrees distribution
and computing the modularity of
industrial instances
what we observe here in blue is that the
modularity is extremely high
so it's even for uh for
real world uh net worth analyzed
for by other people the modularity is
never so high
like in the industrial instances that we
use in the competitions
and the other thing that we observe is
that it seems natural that
this such always tries to destroy the
crosses connecting distinct models
and that tries to read to to increase
the modularity of the formula
but on practice what we observe during
the execution of the sub solver is that
the learning reduces the modularity of
the formula so
somehow it's something that is not
uh taking advantage
by the sub solver probably because
you if you concentrate only in one of
the models of the formula
this is not the north to prove the
unsatisfiability of the formula you have
to consider
several models of the formula
the other thing that we have studied
about the initial instances is the
fractal dimension
the fractal dimension here you have uh
is based on the notion of fractal
dimension for a graph
the idea is if you have a graph
with some self-similarity like this one
you can compute
the number of tiles of radio
air that you need to cover their network
for radio one is just the number of
nodes for
radio equal to the diameter of the
network
it's just one tile and you can compute
the number of tiles that you need
this computation of course is np-hard so
you have you only
you can only compute an approximation of
this number of tiles
and if you compute the number of tiles
for different uh
values of the radio and you observe
a power distribution the exponent of
this power
distribution of n of error in terms of
error defines the the fractal dimension
of the network if you compute the
fractal dimension of a random formula
uh you observe that the random formula
in the in the percolation
threshold so random formulas have in
fact have two
phase transitions one transition is
the point the the fraction of clauses by
variables that
make the formula connected this is the
percolation threshold
and there is no threshold that is the
fraction of clauses by variables that
makes the formula unsatisfiable
so when this fraction for three sin
f is close to 0.17
then the formula becomes connected and
the
formula has a fractal dimension equal to
two
but when the number of clauses is close
to the
saturn set
threshold then the formula has
no fractal dimension and the number of
tiles decrease
exponentially with the num with the
diameter of the tile
in the case of two cmf the percolation
threshold and the sat and sat
threshold coincides so uh
we have that in the in the on the
phase transition in the saturn side
phase transition for two
sets the formula is is
fractured jordy you have five minutes
ah okay uh for industrial instances
uh we observed that most of them have a
fractal dimension in practice
we don't know the fractal dimensions
between two and four but we don't know
how to exploit this property
and the learning does not affect the
fractal dimension
and in the third part of my talk
i would like to talk about the models
for generating stat instances
and we'll describe basically three
models if we want to
generate a random scale free formula
there are
two standard methods one is the verifica
albert
preferential attachment method the
chenglu
configuration model and
we propose a third method that it's
based on the use of hidden
variables the idea is that to generate
uh our formula with a scale free
structure
what we can do is to assign a different
probability
to each variable if this probability
follows a popular distribution with
exponent beta
then what you get is a formula where
derivative of the variables follows a
overload distribution with exponent
delta
and the delta and the beta are related
in this way
uh analyzing the formulas that you get
using this random generation method
you observe that in general the
percolation and the saturn surface
transition decrease
with beta
even it can get be it can be zero in the
case of two sides for instance
when beta is equal to one-half
i think that uh ralph probably will talk
about this
model in this case for the fish
transition analysis
and uh we also observe if we compare
assad solver specialized on industrial
instance
compared with the time required by assad
server specialized on random instances
we observe that we when we increase the
value of beta so
when we make the formula more unifor
when the formula is very uniform the
saturn specializes in random
is more efficient and when the formula
it's very scale free then the solver
specialized
on on industrial becomes more efficient
than the other
so it proves that such solvers
specialized in industrial instances make
use of this scale free structure
we have also analyzed another model that
is the
model for generating random formulas
with modular structure
i will not come into details it's very
simple
and in this case we also observe that
when we increase the modularity
of the generated formula these are
random formulas
the solver specialized the solver's
glucose specialized in industrial
is more efficient than the solar march
that is specialized in random
so it's also that it's also an advantage
for the industrial solvers
and if we generate a
formula where the
here is a formula where only 10 models
and the variables
between 900 and 1000
belongs to the same model and we
observed
the decisions made by the solver along
the execution
we observe that the solver tries to make
decisions on only variables of
a few of the models of the formula
so the form that solver starts to
concentrate the decisions
on the variable so that belongs to one
or
just a few of the models of the formula
finally we have described another uh
way to generate a random formula that is
called popularity and similarity
uh i will not come into detail the
details of
the model
i just want to explain that
in this model it has uh this model has
two properties
in one side there are variables that are
more popular than the others this means
that these variables occur
much often than the others and then this
model also captures the notion of
locality so there are variables that are
close
closer to the others and others
and if we observe the execution of the
search over
along sorting the variables according to
the popularity
then we observe that the solver tries to
make decisions on
more popular variables so on the top of
the variables that the word more often
but at the same time if we sort the
variables according
to the how close they are
one to the other we observe that the
decisions are made
just on a few of these variables so
some way the sub solvers tries to
choose to make decisions they try to
choose those variables that occur more
often
but also the variables that are located
closer to the variables that
were decided before just before so
the solvers uses some kind of heuristics
where it takes into account both
properties
of the of the formula the locality and
the popularity of the variables
well that's all
thank you for your attention